how do women self-improve like what what
ways do you see them do it I think women
they they go like if you don't want to
meet attractive men they're gonna go to
expensive bar they go to the they're
going to Target the kind of men they
want and they're gonna go to specific
places okay so they need to be dressing
properly they need like to have the
plastic surgery they need to make the
nose smaller and then start can I can I
can I just I want to just point out
something that you said notice how you
said plastic surgery before you said go
to the gym
so what does that say about women's
self-improvement doesn't it seem we take
the easy way out oh yeah I think we are
always trying to improve women in
general more than men for sure like more
attractive women than attractive men for
sure
so how so when the majority of women are
overweight so like women have a higher
BMI than men